so you guys might know that i am such a
huge animal crossing fan
but this is a really fun collaboration
between build-a-bear and
animal crossing new horizons so we have
isabelle and tom nook
this is their winter outfits these ones
just came out thank you to nintendo and
build a bear for sending me these to
check out
i'm so excited to unbox them i do have
the original versions that came out
a few months ago also i meant to edit
that down to make a youtube video and
clearly i never did it so now it's a
part of this video flashback
right now i'm doing a live stream here's
all my friends hold on a second let me
pop open the chat box these are my
friends we're doing a live stream on
twitch
and i'm going to be opening up the
animal crossing
build-a-bear collaboration look at
everybody saying hello ugh
i okay so first of all i love animal
crossing if that's new information for
any of you
hi i have over 1100 hours of animal
crossing that i've
racked up over the course of the past
year this game in particular basically
i don't want to say like saved my life
but it definitely
really saved my my 2020. i mean it was
something that
i had so much fun playing i enjoyed
playing it with the audience here
all of my friends over here in the chat
they
really just helped kind of like make
this year really incredible so thank you
everybody over here
all of you
tom nook i can see his little eyeball
he's uh you can tell he's looking for
money yeah tom nook is in the house
he's in my house oh my goodness look at
this
look inside here look at this look at
this oh my goodness oh my gosh oh
here he is oh my god i'm freaking out
dude
this is so oh my god it's so cool
ah man okay wait maddie is maddie look
tom nook tom nook maddie tom nook
[Music]
i'm so happy right now okay so we have
tom nook go we've got the next look at
maddie
he is like what's in there
[Music]
oh my gosh this is so cool
oh it's so great
so perfect i love this shirt too this is
a nice pick
this is a very nice choice animal
crossing build a bear collab
perfect ah it's such a great collab and
i just have loved all of the animal
crossing collabs that they've done
like with makeup there's so many
incredible
just like merch opportunities and really
cool things out there so i'm excited
and a flashback they're so cute you guys
okay i'm just gonna put you here and you
guys can watch me unbox
so this is their winter outfits i mean
for me i'm in the southern hemisphere so
is it winter it'll be we'll be nearing
winter again shortly here
oh my gosh look at your winter outfit
your cute little skirt
and your beautiful little flowered
patterned sweater
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't believe that this game has been
out for over a year when this came out
it was the first day of lockdown and it
was also my birthday so it was kind of
the worst best day ever okay your outfit
is beautiful i'm gonna use this water
bottle to keep your body
propped up you look great isabelle all
right tom nook
i'm sure as soon as i take you out of
this box you're gonna be asking for my
bells you're going to try to take all of
my money
yeah crook but you're a pretty cool
crook and you're also very cute
so oh my gosh his winter outfit is cute
i tried to wear a little winter outfit
number to match my friends
this is so look at this i actually
want this sweater for myself do we have
adult versions of this or even a child's
version and i'll just get a very large
version of the child's version to try to
put it on my body
question mark this is really cute i love
it i absolutely
freaking love it let's let's hear your
sound
[Music]
sounds the same let's do a little
comparison here
between tom nook summer and tom nook
winter
do you even do you even weather do you
even
do you even have season changes
not in los angeles really you look great
tom
let's see summer isabel first winter
isabel i really want to go to the store
and actually like
make a build-a-bear it was honestly such
a fun experience and i never really did
it as a child
i've always made them as adults because
i don't think that this was around when
i was a child because if it was
i would have been begging my mom please
take me to the mall i want to go to
build a bear i want to build a bear
but it's cool because they have so many
different characters now like the fact
that they're doing fun collaborations
like this
super cool that's really the video i
just wanted to show these to you guys
because i just love animal crossing and
i just thought this was such a fun
cute collaboration give me your arm give
me your arm let's just
let's gather around family a group
family hug
is this working out for you
[Music]
family a group family hug is this
working out for you
it's working out for me great
let me know in the comments below let me
know in the comments below what your
favorite video game is and what
got you through the last year
let me know in the comments below what
your favorite video game is and what got
you through
the quarantine what is that is that
doing something what is happening
um okay that's weird
um
let me know in the comments below what
got let me know in the comments below
what your favorite video game is
and what got you through quarantine for
me it was definitely animal crossing and
running
thankfully i did have a treadmill and i
never really had run
prior to lockdown and you know i guess
being locked in with a treadmill at
animal crossing
you never know what you're gonna do oh
yeah you do
you're gonna play nintendo when you're
gonna run that's
what got me through
okay
oh my goodness animal crossing
build-a-bear collab
is here so these are the animal crossing
so build a bear